think of your favorite sports anime
whatever it may be haikyuu hajimino ippo
maybe kurokono basket hajime no ipo
ping pong the animation anything i'd
hope except for keijo hajimino
there's a lot of prerequisites for
sports anime the formula per se but the
two things that they almost always do to
a fault even is a tournament arc and the
theme of friendship
it's almost cheesy the way that a lot of
sports anime format the idea of
friendship being the key aspect tying a
team together above anything else
hell krokono basket's final power-up
lets them enter the shadow realm after
achieving absolute trust in their
teammates
even in hajimeno ipo an anime about
boxing a fundamentally solo sport the
bond between ipo and his coach and
training gym mates is key to the show's
charm
and i like it it's endearing but imagine
this
imagine if a sports manga did none of
that
what if there was a sports manga that
threw friendship out of the window and
followed only the most egotistical pride
driven and independently head strong
players out there as they compete with
each other to get to the top of the
sports world
guess what
that's exactly what blue lock is all
about
sports anime and manga always like to
show off the different positions on
sports teams nishinoya made a position
with no spiking no attacking literally
just defense and receiving into one of
the coolest parts of haiku frankly
shooting guards point guards i only know
the positions on a basketball team
because i watched kurogano basket and
liked all the players put in those
positions if you can't tell my knowledge
of sports is limited to basically only
what i've learned from anime
but once again check this out
a sports manga where the characters all
have the same exact position
yeah
blue lock follows 300 of japan's
strongest strikers which if you're not
sporty unlike myself of course the
sports connoisseur it's basically the
guy in soccer who scores the goals the
main weapon and offensive attacker
and these 300 kids they've all been sent
to this really intense probably very
illegal training facility to train
japan's first world-renowned striker
because to sum it up japan basically
just builds teams full of softies
it's kind of like a criticism of the
friendship theme i was talking about
earlier this manga takes that idea of
friendship and kindness and then just
tosses it into the toilet
bluelock only trains the hardest most
lethal killers on the soccer field and
among those 300 recruited only one wins
and what happens if you lose you might
ask can you just try again like a normal
tournament no no not at all if you lose
in blue lock and get kicked out you are
blacklisted from any professional team
and your future in soccer goes
right down the toilet with that
friendship
bluelock is all about training the
biggest egotist
a striker so incredibly confident in
their abilities that they don't need
that foolish idea of friendship
and what's more exciting than our most
primal instinct to survive and wear the
crown on top of a mound of corpses
metaphorically
but in the form of soccer
and what's easier than reading all of
your favorite manful on one site with an
accessible user interface and daily
manga updates
well you can get all of that with the
sponsor of this video billy billy comics
i feel like with the recent boom of link
click chinese manhua is experiencing
unprecedented and frankly well-deserved
attention at billy billy comics you've
got access to tons of mantwa like
kevin's official blessing which i've
actually cracked open now that i've got
access to it there's a schedule showing
when new chapters update and it's just
really useful overall if you're looking
to get into manhua check out the link in
the description to support not just them
but me too as a creator but back to
bluelock
so even though everyone plays the same
position in blue lock the manga still
creates distinct differences between
each player's individual styles
almost to the point where it doesn't
even feel like they're all strikers so i
guess it's kind of cheating to say all
of these people are the same position
some are really good at dribbling or
shooting from long distances which keeps
it fresh and prevents it from feeling
like a huge sausage fest of a bunch of
cloned dudes trying to score better
goals than each other although that's
pretty fun to read too
and the manga knows that
the characters all have this really sick
aura to them in the art style whenever
they're about to do something crazy and
bluelock really capitalizes on these
awesome moments and makes them epic
the best part about this manga is these
super skilled strikers one-upping each
other repeatedly
the only thing that matters is scoring
goals
after all blue lock doesn't have
anything extra like friendship or a lot
of team bonding i mean there's a little
bit of team bonding but then they all
realize that they're out to beat each
other into the dirt and they're like
wait but because it doesn't have all
these extra parts that normal sports
anime or manga have bluelock really
compensates with its hype moments and
pretty hardcore characters
like nagi who just started playing
soccer six months before the manga
started but is somehow a god among men
already and can stop a full-blown pass
in a second with a little toe touch and
do whirlwind rock lee kicks in the air
to score a goal and then there's this
guy who can score a goal from like 30
meters away which is
this way
a hundred feet that's that's
insane and his whole shtick is that if
he gets to that distance he can score a
goal automatically he is so hardcore and
our main character isagi is
is almost hardcore i'd say
see the thing is manga have to develop
their protagonist in some way at least
one because character development is
really important to a good story
in all the best sports anime and manga
the main characters start with a lot of
potential but it's unrefined
they enter the sports world maybe
surprise someone a little bit but then
realize how outclassed they are until
they train their skills
and of course like any good sports manga
bluelock has this as well
isagi starts off this story by losing in
the road to high school nationals
because at the very end right in front
of the goal that could have tied the
game he chose to pass the ball instead
of just taking the shot
totally uncharacteristic for a striker
plus his teammate whiff they lost the
game like
bro you're trash
and so he's really down in the dumps
afterwards feeling guilty and debating
whether he should have passed or not
when he gets invited to blue lock it is
the perfect opportunity to train him and
make him realize
teammates and so the entire manga's
premise essentially follows isagi
learning to abandon the idea of relying
on friends or teammates
drill into his head to never pass again
in that kind of situation and be so
goddamn cocky and egotistical that he
will always take the shot because he is
100 confident that he will hit it
and he starts out kind of lame he still
believes in the idea of being nice and
friends with everyone but once isagi
gets his first taste of victory he
starts seeing the demon inside of him
come out and it's pretty exciting he
starts getting a lot better he starts
challenging these strikers who were all
way better than him when he first came
in but now he's growing into this
inhumane beast of a striker and it's so
much fun
i mean bluelock is just about the same
as every other sports manga or anime
you've seen except all the characters
have insane drive to win and it's more
competitive it leads to more intense
1v1s the stakes are higher than ever
and instead of losing just a tournament
you lose an entire future in the sport
this is the story of japan's 300 best
strikers being forced into an all or
nothing competition to become the
world's best they are putting their
lives on the line i mean not literally
but
you know the future lives
definitely check it out it's so much fun
and there's an anime that's going to be
adapted in 2022 i think so if you want
to get ahead of the curve
definitely recommend
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses
you